patrick mboyo baca mahbod spécialiste de
la république démocratique du congo et
chercheur en droit public bonsoir
monsieur mboyo baca mobo merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france vous les
connaissez bien ces protestataires c'est
le mouvement des combattants justement
quelle est leur combat et pourquoi ces
manifestations précisément ce soir
j'aimerais d'abord commencé par préciser
que je regrette toute la violence qui
est enregistrée aujourd'hui et que c'est
quelque chose que je déplore que je
condamne fermement
mais j'aimerais pouvoir expliquer à vos
téléspectateurs pour qu'ils puissent
comprendre pourquoi cela se passe-t-il
aujourd'hui sa fille ne vaut que ce
mouvement est apparue c'était exactement
en novembre 2011 que ces mouvements
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui nous avons des
combattants a vu le jour c'était
justement pour bloquer un concert à
l'époque d'une star de la musique
angolaise papa wemba les autres stars
qu'on relise paris oui rassoul pardon à
paris à l'elysée montmartre à l'époque
pourquoi ce mouvement et s'il a t'il été
lancée puisque pendant des années la
musique congolaise a dominé la scène
parisienne il y avait des groupes de
musiciens qui veulent et du congo 4 5
par année pour jouer
remplissez toutes les grosses tall sall
de paris mais dans l'entré temps le
congo coller aux jeux depuis plus de 25
ans une crise politique par exemple
crise politique une tragédie humaine et
humanitaire qui a causé près de 6
millions de dtcc le pays qui a connu la
plus grosse perte humaine depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale et du coup les
congolais de paris et de l'europe ce
soir est saisie on dit on ne le pouvons
pas continuer à danser à paris pendant
qu'on tue chez-nous viol au congo c'est
intéressant le fait de dire on ne peut
plus d'ansé à paris quand on massacre
chez nous c'est en 2011 que le mouvement
a fait ça a commencé plus tôt à londres
en grande-bretagne la grande bretagne
c'était le premier pays où la communauté
congolaise à boycotter les concerts
c'était déjà en 2008 et à paris le
mouvement appelé en 2011 et toute
l'europe a suivi derrière alors ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui sans réalité un
message un message qui vient d'une forte
frustration est bien dit dans mon propos
liminaire que je condamne la violence
mais je veux que les gens comprennent
d'où vient cette violence et bien d'une
frustration du sentiment d'humiliation
que les congolais récente en pensant que
comme s'ils n'étaient pas des êtres
humains 6 millions d
mollet sont morts personne ne cherche à
résoudre ces problèmes et le congo
continue à sombrer encore dans la
violence et jusqu'aujourd'hui parce que
pourquoi parce que bon il est pas
interdit d'être chanteur mais ce
chanteur là en particulier est accusé
d'être trop proche du pouvoir de joseph
kabila pas du tout le cas
le chanteur n'est pas du tout réputé
proche par contre papa wemba et werrason
quand il était bloqué en 2011
eux étaient proches du pouvoir de joseph
kabila maintenant fally ipupa dont je
soutiens la démarche je soutiens la
musique parce que c'est un artiste
engagé en matière humanitaire il fait
des dons il a offert une ambulance dans
une grande ville du kobo qui souffrent
de la guerre bukavu
il avoue faire le raccordement en eau
pour une population à kinshasa 5 et les
autorités n'arrivent pas à faire alors
malheureusement pour lui il est pris
dans une spirale dans un mouvement qui a
été déjà pris et les combats tandis que
tant que le pouvoir en place n'a pas
encore ne s'est pas détaché du rwanda
qui cause des morts au congo est temps
que la communauté internationale ne
s'est pas saisie de la question des
morts du congo puisque tous les jours
des gens meurent abelli au kivu et dans
tout le reste du congo nous allons
continuer à manifester pour faire passer
les messages
et aujourd'hui tout le monde en france
comprend qu'il ya des manifestants qui
protestent parce qu'il ya des problèmes
qu'on vous accusez le rwanda est ce vous
pouvez juste expliqué pour nos
téléspectateurs pourquoi parce que le
rwanda c'est le rwanda qui a soutenu
pratiquement tous les mouvements
rebelles qui ont eu lieu au congo et
c'est l'invasion du rwanda 1996 lors de
l'évasion du zaïre en 96 par le pouvoir
de paul kagame qui a ramené tout tous et
vont de tuer riz qui ont causé 6
millions des morts en république
démocratique du congo très court le le
pouvoir a connu une crise politique
aujourd'hui avec félix tshisekedi qui
est président sauf qu'il n'a pas
beaucoup pouvoir il a m'a mise de joseph
kabila ça aussi c'est quelque chose que
vous exactement parce que normalement
après l'arrivée au pouvoir de tshisekedi
le mouvement aurait dû s'arrêter mais
les combattants rencontrés quelque chose
que kabila est toujours derrière comme
vous l'avez dit il est toujours présent
et tshisekedi s'est fondu dans la
coalition du pouvoir de kabyles mais
dans ce que moi j'ai proposé aux
autorités françaises c'est que c'est une
chanson qui sert espace en france je les
avais déjà prévenu des peas hier en
disant qu'il va y avoir des problèmes la
dernière fois c'était un art notre
artiste héritier watanabe
à l'occasion de son concert on aboulin
véhicule devant l'olympia il ya trois
ans passés c'est en 2010 cette
maintenance et fally ipupa ça va être
plus grave
pensez à nous aider à réorganiser un
dialogue entre des artistes et les
combattants parce qu'il faut leur
trouver une porte de sortie par le haut
ainsi que ainsi les artistes pourront
travailler les virements fait un appel à
un gouvernement français exactement
parce que aujourd'hui au lieu de
mobiliser les forces de l'ordre comme
ils l'ont fait aujourd'hui ça coûte de
l'argent faire évacuer la gare des lions
c'est une perte pour l'économie
française
le mobilier urbain était détruit au lieu
d'en arriver là puisque ceux ci les
combattons aujourd'hui n'empêche pas le
concert de fanny il voit encore réelle
manifester demain fally avait tenté les
jouets en 2011 ça n'a pas empêché les
mouvements de prendre d'autres artistes
vont jouer demain ils eurent encore des
casses et bennoo a organisé un dialogue
entre les musiciens et les combattants 1
sur le rail porte de sortie par le haut
et tout le monde sera gagnant il y aura
la paix en france tranquillement parmi
le combattre comolet bien entendu merci
beaucoup patrick mboyo baqem mahbod
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ont
surgi